the first thing we talk about is just
schools being completely broken and the
general idea about I want to start with
something topical because I guess it's
you who exposed Elizabeth Warren as
being a liar yeah well if you light a
lot but yeah I mean the most recent lie
was the one that I found out lying about
sending her own son to a private school
and I have no issue with her sending her
kids to a private school the issue then
becomes when you lie to a voters face
about it so if you go to my Twitter my
Pinterest want the same options you had
for your kids and by the way I heard
that you sent your kids to private
schools elizabeth warren quickly
responded and quietly that no i sent my
kids to public schools so they know was
a false denial right in regards to the
question about private schools and i was
also the one who found using
ancestry.com that elizabeth warren sent
Alex Warren to a private ancestry.com
yeah I mean a lot of politicians are
being exposed with this with this
website I think Trudeau his black face
incident was found on ancestry.com as
well just like so your books let's break
down the problem with why it was bad
Warren well what lying to your voters to
constituents is wrong but what makes
what this issue in specifically is about
school choice and you have this you have
a website with a map you have a bunch of
states where there are it's basically
entirely Democrats who are advocating
what against school choice saying like
you can't choose where you go to school
yeah so they're fighting against school
choice options such as charter schools
or private school voucher programs
essentially when I define school choice
I went into a little tangent you know
earlier but essentially anything that
allows people to choose their schools
that could be another district school
that can be a charter school magnet
school could be a homeschool option but
it just essentially allows the money to
follow the child just like with food
stamps we don't send food stamps to the
grocery stores and then say you got to
go to that grocery store no we give the
food stamps to the families and say you
can pick a private grocery store here or
there you can go to Trader Joe's Walmart
so essentially school choice is again
just allowing money to follow the
students and then it becomes
hypocritical when politicians deny that
option or opportunity for others
but then at the same time either
currently send their own kids to private
schools or fancy charter schools or you
know in the past sent their kids to
private fancy schools I guess everyone
in the comments will probably have an
answer for this but why is it that so so
let me get this straight
all of the people that you have on your
map all these Democrats are against
people choosing whatever school they
want yep everybody on this map so far
it's only Democrats doesn't mean we
won't put Republicans on there but
there's a Republican out there and any
viewers want to send me a Republicans
name who sent their kids to private
schools or and that also is against
school choice we'll add them to the map
as well and we're more than happy to
take any of these hypocrites off the map
they just have to stop being hypocrites
first right what yeah it's all
throughout the United States so so
here's what I'm hearing you've got
government monopolies on certain public
institutions and your of the position
that people should be able to choose and
not be forced why would a Democrat be
against choice I don't understand it
seems weird well it doesn't make any
sense especially when you look at these
other analogies like food stamps
Democrats tend to be in favor of food
stamps they tend to be in favor of
helping the least advantage financially
so why don't we help them with
essentially food stamps for K through 12
education Democrats tend to be for Pell
grants which are essentially vouchers or
food stamps for higher education they're
for pre-k programs which pre-k pre-amp
programs you get the money you can take
it to a private or public provider of
pre-k it's like a voucher for
what's-what's their argument I mean I
don't know I don't know what the
disconnect is they won't make this they
don't make the argument out loud but I
think what it is is that if you think
about the details I mean the teachers
unions have a strong interest in keeping
the k-12 public school monopoly as is so
because they have a really sweet deal
right now right people are residentially
assigned to your schools and guaranteed
they can't leave like I said this
imagine if you were residentially a sign
to Walmart and you couldn't leave
Walmart unless you pack your bags and
move somewhere else
and imagine if you want to go to Trader
Joe's get your groceries and Walmart got
to keep all your money after you started
shopping at Trader Joe's I want to make
any sense Walmart would love that and
then similarly the teachers unions love
that they love that monopoly power I
don't blame them you know they're
protecting their monopoly
they're doing what they do but I think
that's the issue here and teachers
unions overwhelmingly donate to a lot of
candidates and and right Democrat
Democratic candidates so that could be
part of the issue there but but
logically there's there's it's logically
inconsistent to support other programs
for the least advantaged such as Pell
grants pre-k food stamps Medicaid these
are all vouchers just for other services
but then at the same time say well I'm
not gonna support a voucher for K
through 12 education
sounds like a union thing yeah they
never they don't really have a strong
argument I haven't heard one I know they
usually pivot to something else like
well they'll just start talking about
yeah well we don't want public money
going to religious schools to which I'll
respond well Pell grants do the same
thing you're calling to expand the Pell
right right right Warren Warren called
to expand Pell grants and then she
called to end private school choice
programs in the United States in her
education proposal it's out it she's
supporting both and opposing like she's
supporting both but then opposing them
on specifics it's it yeah and there's
never there's it tends to it looks like
there's never like a logically
consistent argument made by the end I
mean it's always it's always just it
comes you know they'll pivot to
something else which is also logically
inconsistent
yeah it's pom but you know the crazy
thing to me is that this what you're
saying sounds so similar to a lot of
what I've talked about in terms of how
the left of my youth have like gone away
it used to be to me growing up it was
the right that was inconsistent that
what was their logic there were moral
authoritarians religion all the stuff
now Trump's rolling out the LGBT flag
I'm not saying it's perfect on that
stuff mhm you know I always mentioned
that son he's not perfect but now you
have the moral authority Rhian left you
have illogical political positions they
don't want to go on TV they don't want
to talk they're the ones outside with
the signs screaming you know we hate you
and stuff like that it's like this weird
flip has happened I don't want to get
too much into the flip inning but it's
strange for me to see logically
inconsistent wente choice like yeah I
mean they'll try to make the argument
that you know people should just stay in
their public schools and fix their
public schools but you know that's not
helping the least advantaged right and
then warned
do the same thing she pulled her kid out
of the private school school instead and
send them to private school not just sir
a bunch of other people apparently yeah
I mean so a lot of people are doing this
so like like practice what you preach
right if you're gonna talk about how
other people should just stay in their
schools and fix them and this is a lot
of like the Trump rhetoric rhetoric to
that you know if you don't like if you
don't like your country you shouldn't
come here you should stay in your
country and fix your failing country
right Warren doesn't agree with Trump on
immigration but her logic matches his
his right his like emigration back it up
and leave you know it's a little
different obviously because it's
different countries and this is within
your country but it's a similar logic
that you should just fix your failing
schools and it's just ridiculous that
well you didn't do that why does
everybody else why did the disadvantaged
people have to do that
advantage people already have school
choice they go they can live by you know
the most expensive public schools and
they can pay for the private schools out
of pocket would you be at all shocked if
I told you Elizabeth Warren was a liar
no no because you know she's lied about
a ton of other things yeah that's a
prior ancestry and yeah just the latest
one is is the private school lie I mean
she's got a huge list the Bernie Sanders
thing like yeah and like you know she
had no evidence for that she just kind
of said it and like I worked well I
don't know actually I mean she lost she
lost in Massachusetts by a longshot she
got third place right and yeah you know
her own state yikes
and I think that's why she kind of
pulled out today right she pulled out
from yeah sheep sheep she's she bailed
out man she was awful and then of course
what we end up seeing is because she
drops out everyone's like sexism you
know misogyny or maybe it's because
you're lying all the time
yeah maybe a bad person you know and
like and like she came after Bernie and
a lot of Bernie supporters actually came
and started retweeting my tweet with the
lie it's so like warning if you don't
have proof that Bernie said this like if
you don't want to give proof then look
as a third party if someone just sees
like well you lie all the time and
there's no proof either way you know it
doesn't make you look good right so why
even bring it up in the first place if
you're not gonna put the proof forward
because then she can't man she came
after Bernie app at the end of the
debate right she was like I heard you
call me a liar and Bernie just like I'm
not gonna talk about it right now and
then when shake his hand then Tom Steyer
comes in hey this is a saying
there's a weird thing that's kind of
happening that I think kind of explains
the logical inconsistency a lot of these
people I think that are still attached
to say like Warren or or Bernie to us
Bernie to a certain degree and Biden
they're not paying attention so without
throwing shade at anyone specifically I
can point out that you know even when it
comes to YouTube where you have more
independent voices more independent
research a lot of the progressive
youtubers I've seen parrot talking
points without doing research now of
course they'll say the same thing about
moderate conservative voices too but you
know I for me like whenever I you know
do commentary I always start with some
kind of factual basis from a certified
news outlet I use a third-party
fact-checking thing I want to make sure
that if I have an opinion on something
it's based on the like official fact
right but you have a lot of people right
now who will hear tidbits from gossip
about what Warren wants to do about what
she is doing instead of what's actually
going on so what I end up seeing happen
conservatives I feel I feels like I feel
like if it happened when the the media's
consistently consistently been dominated
by leftist or liberal voices forever
like even even though you know John
Stewart the all the political commentary
has always been very left you end up
with a bunch of conservatives and even
moderates centrists who feel like
they're not hearing what you know an
alternative or other opinions so they
start seeking out other ideas and other
concepts you end up then finding a group
of people who will look into Elizabeth
Warren's history they'll look to her
ancestry perhaps they'll see hey wait a
minute she's lying I don't support her
whether or not you're liberal
conservative moderate or otherwise I
think the tendency you know what we're
seeing why we have a bunch of hypocrites
on the Left who support things that seem
to not make any sense principally is
because they don't need to it's because
they know their constituents aren't
gonna go on Google and look it up yes
what think tanks like me going and
looking up you know where Alex Ward yeah
that's cool laughter I start seeing it
because I mean she was started getting
very loud on social media just she
started a new hashtag on public school
proud I went to a public school I taught
at public schools you know and she she's
remained silent about where she sent her
own kids
to school so I mean you got people like
me looking into this and then I've also
been fact-checking media outlets as well
like the Washington Post just a couple
months ago a the Dean of the UVA s curry
School of Education very elite
institution wrote that education
spending decreased in real terms since
the 1980s and there's no way you can say
that it days after they ran this they
finally corrected it but but took them
forever it took a lot of back-and-forth
and it's just like basic facts like that
we should be able to agree on those
things and I shouldn't have to go
fact-check you right but it should
happen already before the fact so what
like what this guy was trying to do is
claim that we've cut funding to schools
is that basically it yep so his whole
thrust of his article was you know hey
we haven't tried this before but hey you
know we haven't tried to spend more
money before that's the one thing we
haven't tried in education that was the
main thrust of the argument and so his
his the the data point that mattered was
was was his talking point that real
education dollars have decreased since
the 1980s and there's no way you can say
that whether you're just looking at the
federal spending just looking at the
state spending just looking at the local
fent spending if you put it all together
in total terms if you do it per student
no matter how you look at it even in the
most conservative scenario real
education spending after adjusting for
inflation has increased by 36% since the
1980s even if used the highest base year
1989 so do you think this guy is a liar
or a bad person like I mean I'm upit I
mean I don't like I don't like to assign
motives to people but look he is the
Dean of an education school he should
know this but at the same time when you
don't have a lot of incentives to be
very competent maybe he didn't know so I
like to assume good motives but I mean
given that he should know this this
seems like it was a lie
would he have benefited from his
proposals yeah I don't know if you would
have benefited personally from
increasing education I don't know if
he's taking you know well I mean like
his field his you know institutions is
there a benefit to his ideology by
pushing misinformation yeah I guess you
could make that argument that if he's
working in the higher education system
if we start spending more on higher
education then you know he could
indirectly benefit you know I don't know
if that was his actual motive
right I don't want to sign motive right
I know but but still like it's like dude
you were like the Dean of an education
school it may be through the Dean of the
business school maybe you can kind of
give him a pass and say like oh you know
this is not his field but this is
education and so like the Philly
Enquirer just like two weeks after the
Washington Post ran this story did the
same thing and said that education
expenditures have been increased over
the last three decades so repeating the
same incorrect statement but yeah like
the Washington Post took forever Philly
Enquirer was a little quicker on the
correction but they both corrected them
but like the Washington Post should have
retracted the piece honestly because
look their their their entire argument
was we haven't tried this before well we
have tried this before doesn't work you
corrected it and yet the paper kept the
headline kept the sub sub headline so I
mean like you know like it shouldn't
take people like me going out and
correcting these things so no I don't
know how to fix it besides you know
private individuals kind of going out
and holding people accountable and I
think this is one of the benefits of
social media in general and YouTube and
and other social media outlets is that
you can apply the pressure right I mean
it takes a certain amount of following
but if you have the facts on your side
and the news outlet is its publishing
verifiably false statements then other
even if you don't have a lot of
followers someone who does have a big
following will see this ho but you know
and share it what's what one of the
things I think is beginning to happen is
there there there's always been an
imbalance between what the media reacts
to right so with what was what was the
recent thing that the GOP sees a Chuck
Schumer Chuck Schumer said oh you know
gorsek Cavanaugh he like you know you'll
never know it's gonna hit you you see
that story right mm-hmm so the story
wasn't you know Chuck Schumer issues
veiled threat or warning it's you know
called out for it
the story was GOP pounces GOP seizes the
media is completely imbalanced over if
you know look if a Democrat does it if
Republican does it just say they did it
instead the story was the reaction from
Republicans instead of the actions of
the individual so what ends up happening
with social media I think we're heading
towards a future where it's not gonna
matter anymore because you're gonna see
businesses whose entire base is going to
be leftist
and so if you know you or I are like a
look warns lying there's no incentive
for any of these institutions
politicians or otherwise to actually
correct it because the like our
customers are left anyway so let's just
lie right but we do have an emergence of
fact-checking organizations which kind
of helps as well but then even even then
people will say the fact-checking
organization right biased what's the
which they're doing I don't listen to
them right well but Snopes is trash
right yeah unless there are some good
fact-checking organizations and but like
you and I know that Snopes you know is
what they do left leftward biased you
know but like the people on the left
will say no this is good you're just
saying that because you're you're not
leftward bias you know you're right here
I'll tell you the trick they do I think
I've seen Snopes do this several times
let's say Donald Trump is seen eating an
a chocolate ice cream cone on the in the
Rose Garden and everyone on Twitter
starts saying whoa Donald Trump was
eating a chocolate ice cream cone if
it's bad information for the left Snopes
will say did Donald Trump really eat a
chocolate ice-cream cone in the Rose
Garden
Dada dot with a handkerchief in his
pocket false and they'll give you this
big long with an explanation at the
bottom while Donald Trump was eating the
ice cream cone he did not have a
handkerchief well nobody said he did
they add little tiny bits to make the
whole thing whole thing false and then
with with NBC my favorite is when Trump
in 2016 said Hillary Clinton acid-washed
her server like it's a figure of speech
they fact-checked at us he didn't
actually use acid right it's a but it
literally said that it said it said the
the Hillary Clinton did not use a
corrosive substance to on her server
what did you do did you see the recent
stuff with Snopes
fact-checking Babylon B of course what
the heck and that but listen use a
satire site come on so here's what
happened
it's like what I was saying before why
why would you find that Warren can
actively hold two disparate like two
different positions that make no sense I
am for Pell grants but against vouchers
when it's like you're saying it's well a
lot of people will just defend her and
say you know well it's because whatever
you know it's because it's for younger
kids no no kids they're gonna say you're
a bigot well yeah they just don't like
war is a woman will attack your motives
they'll say look you you know you just
want you know you don't want to help the
least advantage kids
the public schools it's like no the
lease advantage are stuck in the worst
government-run schools today we should
allow them to pick schools just like the
rich do already say so like they'll
respond with things that just don't make
any sense
so they'll still back her up but then
for a long time the argument was well
Pell grants are for higher education and
those are adults you know and these are
kids we're talking about it's different
well ok then do food stamps food stamps
or vouchers or kids that are that you've
used by the parents that the parents
decide how to how to allocate that money
but then also pre-k pre-k is is
education as well and it's for even
younger kids so why is it any different
between the years of K through 12 it's
not it's like I think I think youyou
pointing to the unions might be a factor
as to why they're for something that
might be you know the principally
opposed to but I think all it really
comes down to is when you have
fact-checking organizations that are
overwhelmingly Left news institutions
that are in major cities that are
overwhelmingly left and increasingly
young ideologically you know corps of
writers and I'm doing air quotes you're
journalists you're gonna end up with
fake news you're gonna end up with
weasel tactics to promote fake news and
you're gonna end up with people who
instead of going online and searching
for themselves just see the man on TV
say and say ok and they get away with it
yeah I mean and you're right it depends
on their base a lot of the times I'll
call this stuff out on social media and
think like well why are they even
correcting it sometimes they won't right
so like so like in Orlando there's they
have the Orlando Sentinel and they've
been saying for a long time that their
school choice program is publicly funded
I mean this is not something that bicker
about it's a really nuanced thing in the
debate but it's a tax credit scholarship
program their courts have ruled it as
privately funded because they're funded
through donations and the Supreme Court
the United States in 2011 also ruled
that these dollars are private dollars
because they have entered the tax
collectors hands they're still private
donations but it's like little basic
facts like this but they wanted they
want their narrative is that public
dollars are going to privates right
right they want to keep that narrative
and I call them out week after week
every time they keep publishing a new
study on this because it seems like you
know used air quotes for journalists
I'll do that as well in certain cases
like this because look once they've been
told what the actual truth is and
they've been given that evidence and
they don't change their narrative and
they keep using the same
all statements that's when it it moves
from journalism to you know to having an
agenda I was in Ukraine in I think it
was twenty end of 2013 when it was like
the big protest which sparked you know
the current conflict it was like I don't
know if you know a lot about it but
basically people rise up as did the
president and there was a story from I
it was a British news organization that
was just completely wrong in every way
because they didn't actually come down
and cover anything they just had someone
write a script about what they thought
was happening based on probably other
reports and so you know I had at the
time not the biggest following but I had
like seventy thousand followers maybe so
I tweeted at this person like hey I'm
here on the ground right now this is not
true I was literally at this event and
they said I don't care the journalist
was just told to read the copy and said
it's all about the narrative right in
the headline but that wasn't even it it
was pure and it was laziness it was it
was like incompetence not really they
knew had a Google search and they just
didn't care so when they were given the
correct information
the response was hey man they just had
me a script and I read it so so did you
blast this out to your followers on
social media and and they never grabbed
help never corrected it nope did people
that you know get upset about it at
least like any of your followers well
yeah of course but it's like that's your
side already right these people are
already supporting you in it like it's
like really like there are some people
out there that'll see this and they'll
see this and they'll see both of the
evidence and there are some convincing
people right I'm sure there are people
who saw the light and saw the truth and
so I think there's still value in
sharing the truth it really is it really
is mind-blowing to me how you know like
I'll give you another example the reason
things like this persist and then we can
move on to like you know peripheral
subjects and stuff maybe we can talk
about how you know what I wanna talk
about how this is like a perfect like
reason why socialism makes no sense but
I
there was a speaking of Warren there was
a censorship thing that just happened to
some progressives and I called it out
and I was like like we've all been
saying they're coming for you next
because you're the Bernie people they
want Biden don't be surprised when the
chrony establishment comes after you and
I get some guy tweeting at me like then
why won't you speak up in defense of war
and when she calls out Facebook and I'm
like bro I do all the time they're like
well why don't you call it the
censorship of the left I'm like
bro I do all the time these people don't
pay attention they don't read they don't
watch and then they just end up eating
this garbage from fake trash media and
that's why they rally behind people with
no principles who send their kids to
fancy private schools while advocating
no one else should be allowed to do it
they don't care there's one of the keys
to the castle and I think I saw one of
your recent tweets on this you retweeted
someone who is pointing out that someone
just quoted Biden or something and they
got their accounts suspended that was
the night they're just you know
reporting the litter yep of what someone
else said and they got blocked for like
tampering with an election or since
exactly ridiculous you reap what you sow
man but but imma come look I don't it
you know I can chuckle like haha the
people who like I don't think this guy
specifically I don't want to drag him
because he's a journalist I don't I'm
not gonna give him air quotes I think is
a progressive guy but he's more of an
independent voice so I'll give him
credit for pushing back on a lot of the
BS at least sometimes but too many of
these people who are aligned with that
side gloated and laughed as big tex
started censoring and shutting down you
know independent voices for whatever
reason so look I'll chuckle but I'm
still opposed to these big companies
doing this but the thing is you know not
not to not to get into a big censorship
conversation so what do you think about
alternative you know platforms I know we
have a ton of you know or just a couple
of big platforms you ain't got Twitter
and Facebook but what do you think about
alternatives do these black platforms
and people kind of switching over
platforms because of the issues yeah
that's that's that's why competition is
so important and again proves why
socialism is is a really really bad idea
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you